[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
rockstar's daily live news show coming
right from our actual break room here at
new rockstars headquarters we're
bringing you the nerdy news of the day
all the fun discussions you want to be
having but for some reason you're not
but we are so you can watch us have them
i guess i'm joined here by brandon
barrick oh hello great to see you all
hope you're having a great day i'm not
finished zach okay
live
well that's good uh back back from a
brief hiatus here jessica clemens good
to have you back i'm very happy to be
back it's feeling great to be here
yeah zach i'm not finished
and uh never left mr tommy back told
episode three wasn't mid
your bed
you're all
me okay
i'm done
okay all right we will be talking uh
episode three of obi-wan definitely
today uh we're also gonna be talking uh
stranger things and that whole kind of
volume of episodes that dropped we got a
little marvel news all that kind of
stuff and today as we do most days we've
got our swear job
yesterday this swear jar was
free-flowing that thing was over first
thing yes sir yes do you guys
real quick one second camera four come
here oh no he's still doing this oh no
listen to me
yesterday you redeemed yourself barely
barely and it was just a few of you but
the rest of you
keep your hands jammed in your stingy
pockets
we're going to notice okay i'm going to
come to your houses pretty soon all
right some of you don't live far you
tweet at me that you know where we are
i'm going to come to your house and i'm
going to shake you upside down oh like a
small bully oh the the tommy bechdel the
sewage knight of
the
road panel
that's what he's known as in paris yeah
tommy was threatening when we hit a
hundred dollars in super chats it
unlocks our swear jar but then we'll
allow one of the panelists to unleash a
tirade of profanity otherwise we're not
supposed to be cursing at all that's
right as as demanded by the uh fcc and
the the lords of youtube uh but when we
hit 100 bucks or any multiple of 100 it
lets us uh get real profane for you so
we appreciate everybody that's in the
chat that's watching live and certainly
if you're throwing in super chats much
love to you we'll try to call out those
questions as we go if you have some
strong opinions thoughts theories on
obi-wan episode three
throw those in the chat we'll try to get
to those later uh but for now let's do
some headlines
okay this is something we've been
covering we've talked about a couple of
times so there was this big to-do when
disney listed hawkeye as a limited
series for any consideration right and
those are usually things that don't have
second seasons whereas they did list i
believe
loki and one division as just series
one division has a limited series but
then loki they submitted as like a show
yes like because they knew they were
gonna have a second season in that show
right so now they have reversed course
and they have relisted hawkeye
as a series
so that has driven some speculation are
we gonna get a season two of hawkeye a
lot of people have been saying well echo
season one will basically be a hawkeye
season two i know i think we could see
either
further adventures of kate bishop before
our young avengers like possibly like a
maybe a kate and jelena type of thing
yeah uh
i don't know that necessarily we're
gonna get like a jeremy renner full
hawkeye second season but possibly a
complete passing of the torch yeah i
love that idea of like uh kate bishop
like going to find elena or something
like that or yeah officially taking over
the hawkeye mantel right you know and
maybe she gets recruited by val but
doesn't know bowser
or or nick fury and she's just straight
up uh agent of shield yeah um e.t online
speaking of um future disney plus series
uh reporting that flight attendant star
griffin matthews has been cast in an
unknown recurring role in marvel
she-hulk coming out on disney plus uh in
the not-too-distant future
and he had this great quote he said
never before did i think somebody like
me would get cast in the mcu
um that's pretty cool we don't know the
fact that they haven't said
what role he's playing he's not in any
of the trailer obviously so there's been
some speculation could he be a
super-powered individual she's defending
maybe it seems like we're going to get
some of those
they're done shooting that show are they
still like making episodes do you think
they've shot everything even if they
shot everything they're going back to
eddie yeah yeah and they may i mean it
seems like marvel is one of those things
as is disney star wars after disney take
over they're constantly tinkering with
these projects
i mean i have a feeling there is going
to be a dearth or a wealth of kind of
like some of the sillier marvel
characters making appearances in
she-hulk so i i don't know that that
necessarily could be this actor but i do
think like there is a chance we're gonna
see some like
you know kind of funnier characters that
need legal help like what they did with
like suicide squad maker where they're
like oh let's have fun with the crowd i
care i think it'd be more fun and this
is pretty lame to just see him as a
prosecutor because it could be from the
point of view of like this person killed
a lot of innocent people i don't want
them on my streets again fair so it
could be like one of those uh before we
do another headline i can see now that i
may have upset everyone in the snapchat
and i just want to
i rarely do this
double down
no no ridiculous no tight pocketed no
selfish people you're being you know how
hard it is for me not to swear for an
hour it's really freaking hard what the
heck man
anyway okay thank you tommy
it's gonna be like every other 10
minutes
tommy's gonna go home the only way yeah
the only way you can quench this rage
folks is by throwing a couple of
doubloons in the old super chat i also
want to call out um you said uh dirth
wealth is one of my favorite sith lords
you guys
remember the story of dearth wealth
he was the first sibling to ever get
into pornography okay
i thought you're going to banking or
something like that like no no no no no
it's very close to dirk diggler
okay um speaking of casting deadline is
reporting the suicide squad uh breakout
actor daniela melchior i think she
played catcher two right beauty uh she's
gonna have a small role in guardians of
the galaxy vol 3. uh we don't know who
she's playing there was some speculation
maybe playing the character moon dragon
james gunn is denying that online which
of course maybe he would no matter even
if she was playing moon dragon um james
gunn if you could ever book anything
with james gunn that guy will keep
putting you to work he loves using the
same actors in all his different
projects well she's also like relatively
new like when he casted her he was like
i wanted to see who would be well which
is also a weird thing who would go well
holding a rat who looks the best holding
a rat and she was the only person that
was like comfortable being like can i
have more yeah so put more rats on yeah
that was a terrible breakdown all these
actors trying to find rats to bring to
the audition like i gotta bring
that's so easy be happy she's not the
spider catcher or something if they were
like here's a bunch of tarantulas on
your head i'd be like oh these
tarantulas are going to die tonight like
i'm going to smash them to be fair there
are a lot of actors in hollywood with
gerbils
at the ready
no no
no thank you tommy
[Music]
deadlines also reporting that isabella
merced previously maybe her best-known
role the live-action dora the explorer
is uh going to be in madame webb madame
webb i don't know why i'm a damn i know
i can't pronounce anything um
again in an unknown role but they we've
already found out of course uh sydney
sweeney's gonna be on that of course
dakota johnson playing madame the mata
um lots of lots of talented young
actresses getting put in this movie we
don't know what any of them are going to
be doing but yeah i made this joke
earlier like craven's getting all the
boys and madame webb is getting all the
latest yeah
it's like the the the boys in the girls
school across the lake from each other
well uh a little birdie told me that
morbius and vulture are putting the team
together
guess who just got back
hey it's morbid time okay it's you know
what at the break room
it's always morbid right no it's not
i'll tell you right now
we have a morbid fascination with that
movie
uh in an interview with steele saunders
from steel wars john favreau teased the
future crossover events of characters in
the mando verse uh he wasn't specific on
details we did confirm that as we see
more of these characters from uh
mandalorian season three book of boba
fett and soon ahsoka uh they will
inevitably cross paths again and we've
already seen ahsoka shown up in both
mandalorian season two and booker boba
fett obviously mando himself din jarin
showed up in book of boba fett
boba showed up in mandalorians so
they've already kind of but like kind of
defenders ask they all join forces i
mean it was a bit of an evasive answer
that was like kind of like yes don't
worry but also i'm not going to tell you
anything about this and i think kind of
the meat if you watch the whole
interview is basically
him saying as the situation gets more
dire
for these characters or gets more
intense or more
on a grander scale they'll inevitably
have to help each other so like there's
probably a scenario where ahsoka is
going to save the day for
mando at some point again vice versa and
and and not just those characters but
your fennec shan's your grow goos a lot
of these like uh other characters in
those
mads mayfield or migs mayfield yes bill
burris
we've talked about before like the fact
that none of these characters show up in
the force awakens or any of that trilogy
are they gone for good they're a final
endpoint for all of these characters
yeah or they all perish rogue one style
i don't know
well speaking of uh
characters we know can't perish rogue
one style let's talk about last night's
episode of obi-wan kenobi yeah um we
specifically want to talk about that
fight sequence right the confrontation
between obi-wan and vader we have a lot
of strong thoughts about
the nature of that fight the outcome of
that fight some of the motivations first
off
everybody here agrees that's not the
last time we're going to see those
fights
they gave us a little tease yeah but it
can't be the the last fight that they
have no no no no no i think it was like
you know it was like just a little taste
we're gonna see it like it was i don't
think either i mean darth vader we saw
how vicious he was but i wasn't
particularly like wow those are two
great fighters i love that scene
[Laughter]
everybody on the yeah oh he just went
it means nothing to that man yeah oh god
i love him he wasn't outright stated but
he was doing that just to draw out
right he didn't think any of these
people knew anything he was just
torturing people because he knew that
would help draw out i really liked i
liked uh with the woman that he's kind
of just like force herding yeah and
she's like the scream she likes it
reminds me of like when han solo was
getting tortured oh right i hear him
scream from the other room like that's
like a very effective like this is dark
this is heavy you love that you tweeted
me like five angel emojis oh i was like
blessed finally someone you're doing a
live watch back and you're like this is
what i like this is what i like as long
as everyone knows this is brandon
barracks type of star wars it's just
enhanced interrogation
get out of here what is this the bush
administration oh
yeah what is this uh 2002 um
that wouldn't be appropriate for prequel
talks but um uh well
a lot of the speculation online and even
in our office has been
obi-wan looking rusty yes everyone's not
putting up the kind of fight now you are
on firmly in the stance of he's just
he's literally just rusty they're not 10
years
that was the best he could do at that
stage of his life last night
i think so i was i was shocked i thought
he would never pull the saber either but
i love the instinct if that had to come
out because i did like when he looked at
it and he was like nah i'll stick with
the blasters for a little bit uh but as
soon as he thought he was in danger and
like that force kicked in he like whips
it out right yeah i was so irritated at
the first scene when he pulled it out he
was like no and i was like you're going
again
black in the dark of the desert and you
cannot see him you are having a hard
time pull the saber out you stupidity
no you you need the darkness so your
eyes are adjustable
darth vader has his full mask on darth
vader's like he's can't use them stupid
i think that
there's i think that a lot of the force
that in my opinion from what we see in
star wars is mental it requires focus it
requires your mind to be at peace i
think obi-wan kenobi is still so blames
himself for everything that for not
recognizing palpatine's seduction of
anakin to the dark side that part of the
reason he is ineffective in this episode
is that he is still not mentally healed
so yes of course he's older
of course he's like you know he's going
to have you know he's eventually going
to be alec guinness so it's like yeah
he's not as strong maybe or as quick as
he used to be he's not that bad there's
no way he could be that bad maybe he's
out of practice like you said but i
think there is a certain part of it that
is
he no longer believes in himself as much
as he once did yeah because he was a
very arrogant jedi for a long time and
the jedi order basically fell apart
under his and master yoda's watch yeah
all these kids got he had a terrible day
this guy has ptsd yeah all these kids
got murdered under his punch well and
that that's his best friend he thinks he
kills his best friend yes we're gonna
talk about the current season the
stranger things a little bit but like
yeah that makes me think both of what
you both said and kind of from watching
the show right the show is in a lot of
ways about trauma dealing with that we
see how anakin has dealt with it both
physically the trauma of having his
limbs severed right it's kind of turned
him hard right he's gotten stronger he's
become more fierce and like driven and
it's kind of turned obi-wan inward right
and he's become more reserved maybe
scared maybe full of doubt self-doubt
yes
i feel like it's i want this is just a
note on like the writing of it i want it
to be i want it to push a little bit
more so i feel that same reaction to
that i feel like it's really hard for me
i'm like
after hearing what you said to you i was
like oh yeah i feel really bad for
kenobi i've been watching all the star
wars but i'm like this is obi-wan kenobi
this is the kenobi series i need them to
really push it for me i need to feel
that obi-wan kenobi's feeling what he's
feeling and i haven't gotten there yet
i'm like i'm still mad i'm like a baby
leia is running around
yeah
like all this stuff is happening and you
are not trying hard enough but i know i
can agree with him i just need to be
pushed i need that anymore i i like the
fact that he's rusty and he's bad he
slips up and says lay his name yeah and
i like the juxtaposition of the
the woman who's the imperial officer
being like here obi-wan kenobi yeah
you're awesome you're incredible he's
like no i'm i'm terrible i'm just dead
now and i saw some people in the chat
mentioning like why does vader let him
go kind of and like not go through the
fire and get him i think vader
is pissed mainly because he's been
itching for this fight for 10 years he's
been practicing he's been getting
stronger he's been killing people left
and right he wants to fight his master
and show how good he is he finally
tracks him down draws him out and his
master sucks and he's like this is
terrible this isn't the fight i'm
looking for someone he's disappointed
never meet your hero someone did just
say that in the super chat they said
obi-wan was holding back and vader was
toying with his people yeah that did
seem like it did definitely the vader
part makes sense to me like it did seem
like he was like i'm having a lot of fun
with this i think
i am still irritated at that fire scene
and him not just
going through it i thought it would have
been like a bad butt can't say curse
words thought it would be a bad butt
scene where he's walking through the
fire flames and i was like oh yeah but
he just stood there and i was like
frankenstein get over there yeah i was
like don't fight them yeah you don't
want to burn your cape that's right it
goes all the way to the ground we saw
that shot um also we don't know those
whatever those red crystals are yeah
they might be burning like ten thousand
yeah this is serious fire we're talking
space fire
it doesn't need oxygen i don't know i
don't want to point out mo and the super
chat said that dirt wealth did some
things that could be considered
[Laughter]
the legend of dirt wealth will only grow
on this show it is cannons and grow was
intentional as well
uh some would argue grow goo
okay
i think is uh the name uh saying uh
qui-gon teased hard possibly liam cameo
soon
keeps invoking his name if nothing maybe
even just a voice
cameo do you think he never comes back
do you think quaggan has talked to
obi-wan at any point in these 10 years
and that's why he keeps reaching out
i think he's been reaching out for 10
years i also think there's a chance that
it could be a not a red herring but a
misdirect where he reaches out for
qui-gon and perhaps
ends up communicating with someone else
like ends up like oh no not you sir
no i mean like
a living yoda like like in a live yoda
is like i'm also reaching out for
qui-gon and i can't get a hold of him
yeah do you think uh yoda and obi-wan
are talking at all during all this are
they are they just not risking it no i
think they're not i don't think obi-wan
is not talking to anybody right because
he doesn't want to risk drawing any
attention to luke and leia right uh we
did a poll in the chat and it seems like
overwhelmingly you guys think that vader
is definitely holding back 87
wow saying that vader's holding back in
this fight i think that's true uh you
know we've talked a little about the
comics that have come out about darth
vader which are great uh ever since when
disney by uh lucasfilm and started
putting out the comics because they
owned marvel too uh there's some really
good darth vader comics and it really
shows how
powerful he is and how like deadly he is
we got a taste of that like in rogue one
where he just has that slasher scene in
the hallway but like he's doing that all
over the galaxy from day one pretty much
well and that segues nicely with
a
do we think that's hidden
christensen under the costume i want to
know b
is that hayden christensen's voice
because it sure sounds a whole lot like
james earl jones right
and we got just the glimmer of a hidden
christmas kind of mirage off in the
distance right
and and presumably that might be him
under all the prosthetics when we're
seeing back to tank vader i think it is
yeah i mean it seems like
they they build it so hard like crazy
for it i hope it's him in the suit we
talked about it yesterday he hired a
movement coach so like we had some great
modeling done yesterday zach an
award-winning model now that's true but
there must i but there was one day where
he's like i don't want to do it dude
just get that yeah we're talking about
how
in boba fett uh the all the mando scenes
he never takes his mascot for like is
that pedro pascal well it's not it's
it's uh it's uh what's the guy's name
sean wayne and then the other guy they
were i mean pedro introduced them
to celebration but yes i don't know if
you guys have heard i recently went to
star wars celebration but no pedro
introduced the two
other he goes these we the three of us
make the mandalorian and like
and and that and i remember you know i
the i i've told you guys my old boss at
my restaurant i worked at his brothers
with one of the stunt doubles or one of
the body doubles fermino and they said
that they practiced walking like each
other okay so that they're watching line
up
anyway i i assume similarly there's
probably two or three darth vaders i
don't know i don't think so and why i
don't think so is because hayden
christensen has been waiting for this
moment to come back he's been like i've
been waiting to be dark
let's be honest he's waiting to give me
back but then he's in the suit
it's 89 degrees in the valley or
wherever they're filming and he's
filming his scenes and walking around
and it's like well we got the other guy
standing by and he's like maybe three or
four hours in as you start to go let's
get the other guy i'll be in my trailer
that's why the fight's at night because
that's a good point i'm hoping like
episode six or part six yeah during the
fight uh obi-wan gets a good hit at the
helmet and like we get like the cracked
helmet you see hayden's face under there
all burned and scabbed over that would
that would be great and the voice the
credits do say james earl jones yeah but
it sounds like a young james i i do
think it's still young i think
they did it if they can de-age people
they easily can be like let me just make
sure this voice be a little bit later i
think we yeah we have enough james earl
as as darth to have like a pretty tight
sound yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean they can recreate
all those times it said james earl jones
voice james earl jones like junior maybe
that's what imdb says i know we can't if
they start if they start doing field of
dreams quotes though that's what i mean
build it and they will only want
everything that the light touches
yeah yeah all right
um
well speaking of people that are holding
up great james earl jones has been old
for about 50 years already
good for him uh you know what else to
keep you feeling nice and young
athletic greens thank you
greens for sponsoring today's show uh
we've got we've got a little um shaker
of it right here that i might down as
soon as i'm done reading this uh in
every scoop of ag-1 which is kind of the
signature product of athletic greens you
get 75 high-quality vitamins minerals
probiotics and other good stuff it's
basically a back to tank you can drink
that's right and i put vader in like a
whole thing of
he'd come out looking more yoda yeah
probably space probiotics um
and and we talk about this a lot you
know maybe like tommy last week traveled
down to anaheim he's at a convention
maybe you're running around i got i got
something i gotta go to right after work
i don't know if i'll have time to grab
dinner maybe you just
ate a whole bunch of gummy bears
in the kitchen because they happen to
stock in the kitchen with gummy bears
today interesting scenario and you're
like well i didn't get the kind of good
stuff i need to be like feeling good to
be at my best athletic green's got you
covered that's like a little insurance
absolutely for your diet you might be
asking where is my ag-1 formula today
it's gone because i drink it already i
can confirm that i saw your shaker in
the sink you already uh nailed your ag-1
there good for you tommy uh he's a big
fan of it we're all big fans of it here
and you too
uh
fans of the break room can be a fan of
athletic greens because right now it's
time to reclaim your health and arm your
immune system with convenient daily
nutrition this guy uh just throw a scoop
in some water no need to have a million
pills and powders
and if you order right now athletic
greens is going to give you a free
one-year supply of immune supporting i
don't i almost said a moon supporting uh
vitamin d no moon but hey that's right
you're not old or wrong um and five free
travel packs with your first person
hired today all you have to do
just like obi-wan
all you have to do is visit
athleticgreens.combreakroom
or click the link in this video's
description you know what when you click
the link you not only save some money
get some free stuff from athletic greens
you also make us look great here on the
on the break room and that helps us and
we appreciate you for that so uh take
ownership of your health pick up the
ultimate daily nutritional insurance
thank you to athletic greens uh we also
want to shout out there's an obi-wan
latest obsession shirt available for
sale currently at new rockstarsmerch.com
none of us have one but we're i think
we're getting one soon especially
oh yeah oh yeah i can't wait to get my
latest obsession obi-wan kenobi shirt
it's gonna be fitting so good and so
soft
okay great okay
how how might uh uh
darth wealth
try on that shirt
give me that shirt
men's medium oh my god let me put it
over my torso
and then you rip it off oh
whoa
dirt as well yeah
yeah it is this ain't star wars okay
uh
speaking of things that ain't star wars
yeah
i don't know guys oh what's wrong tommy
you know i'm just having a tough time
today i've been a little oh down in the
dumps i'm sorry this feels like maybe
some of my emotions are
optional
but you know it's not optional
mandatory fun
that's that wow
that's right
it's the segment so nice we play the
graphic twice hit it again
oh my god it's a segment so fine we
played the graphic three times hit it
again
unstoppable segment that never leaves
you wanting more so we play that graphic
oh no
mandatory fun where i gather my three
best friends in the whole wide world
undisputably we all feel the same way
about each other the super chats are
rolling in because everybody knows this
is when it's time to have fun mandatory
fun and today we're gonna keep the
conversation rolling around obi-wan
invaders
let's just say makeup sex that they had
last night
uh
you know it was definitely foreplay it
was not uh
let's play force oh
vader got the upper hand but he didn't
finish him off oh boy regretted that one
immediately
see this is how we have to work around
the swear jar
anyway we need an innuendo jar yeah
so vader got the upper hand
i got me thinking as he was raking
obi-wan across the coals
we all have grievances in our families
and in our hearts and you know against
uh certain tv shows or movies or people
that just anger us and i thought vader
got his chance to get a little revenge
on obi-wan and he delivered some pretty
choice lines he said you should have
killed me when you had the chance he
said now you will feel how i felt or
whatever something along those lines now
you'll feel the pain that i failed
so i thought for mandatory fun
we could each take a moment to look into
the camera
and air out some grievances and break
some enemies of ours across the coals
who wants to go first
i'll go first great
james
brian
beck told burns
my nephew oh
you're turning 13
friday hey happy birthday and i bet you
think you know everything but there's
one thing
throughout the history of our
relationship as uncle and nephew that
you've refused to know and that is
the magic and majesty of the star wars
franchise you've refused to watch star
wars movies with me in fact i once had
to trick you your dumb little
seven-year-old brain
into going to see rogue one with me by
telling you it was a movie about aliens
and weapons and kind of basically
implying it might have been predator but
it wasn't it was rogue one and you
watched it in the end you said i didn't
like that movie but i didn't hate that
robot
what a cop-out
you like star wars in fact i'd say you
love it so all i ask is you enter your
teenage years a year
i think we get all great time period
where people are known to be open-minded
and you know malleable and compassionate
and not self-centered at all that you
open up your heart to the star wars
galaxy
and you open up your heart to your old
uncle tom because i to be honest if we
don't watch the original trilogy
together this summer i'm disowning you
as a no oh whoa
[Music]
looks like this family tree
just lost a limb oh no
wow we should have wished him birthday
when we had a chance
wow happy birthday james sorry james
had to rake you across the coast wow
look at this flame graphic we got nice
nice work uh producer john powell uh you
guys got one yeah yeah i got one i got a
mortal enemy out there who needs to know
the truth okay
i'm talking to you person in my
apartment building who leaves your
laundry in the shared laundry machine
well past the time that's on the
machines i'm waiting to do my laundry
and your stinky wet clothes mold inside
of the machines have the respect for the
people in the building there's only so
many machines but so many tenants and we
all have skid marks we need to clean
them before our wife leaves them
hit your machine or i will empty out the
lint trap and drag your corpse across it
covering it in the detrious of so many
people's linty belly buttons
you're unnoticed person in the apartment
building refuses to empty the laundry
machines
i will find you there's only so many
apartments and i've got unlimited time
on my head
oh we're gonna have to add some sheets
of softener because that was hardcore
wow wow i love that we've all got skid
marks part of that yeah
quite frankly yeah i'm not trying to be
a butthole but this this uh the voting
has already started and two of us have
not started our first i know you're
already voting how do you know jessica's
probably about to drive we got over a
hundred dollars
oh it looks like tommy's running away i
started a fight about
something i thought the same thing
jessica i sometimes you you know you
when you miss it you miss it i just want
to fight someone i get it well if you'd
love to fight somebody would you like to
drag somebody across the car i can't
drag someone across the coals
um
this is to my ex or should i say exes
because in one form or another you have
downplayed how much of a nerd i am when
i started watching star wars you thought
it was because of you
boy please it was because of darth maul
oh
when i started getting into marvel you
thought it was because of you
nah
nah nah nah it's for all the black women
that are in the marvel cinematic
universe now and all the ones in the
black the black people in the comics i
never got into any of the nerd stuff
because of you if anyone has anything to
own up for my nerdism it's my mother
it's my mom who's the number one nerd
because she birthed a mega nerd
all the exes i've ever had that said i
only game for attention or that i only
do half the things i do all these nerd
tattoos on my body i just got for fun
you think that mothra for fun no it's
because she's a badass woman it's
because she is the princess she is the
queen and so am i mother i'm not gonna
curse because he gets it but let me tell
you right now
who's laughing now cause i'm on your
screen i'm on your phone i'm on your
social media i'm being paid to talk
about the nerd [ __ ] that you only read
about
you thought wrong
bet you saw you saw the last of me huh
yes
i feel the hatred
the earthquake is getting engorged
yes wow
okay that was good well okay so tommy
did a uh reverse drag across the cold
which somebody really likes brandon did
one for an anonymous uh laundry person
jessica did a very impassioned one for
an entire subgroup of humans that have
been close to her different parts of her
life uh okay well i had a couple options
coming into this but i i've been
inspired all right i wanna
i wanna talk to you
my first boss out of college
okay
yeah you know what you took a chance
on a fresh-faced kid who just moved to
los angeles from florida okay and you
know what i appreciate that for you you
you mentored me you took me under your
wing for the that six weeks in which i
was employed and then
and then you turned okay
there was that day i i walked into the
office you even gave me keys been
working for you for six weeks 23 year
old kid i had keys
i had keys i opened up the office you're
already there waiting for me standing at
my desk
well that's unusual you never come in
this early
what's that what are you saying to me
i'm
fired
fired from my first job after six weeks
oh you you you put your trust in me and
now you take it away from me
well no i take it back from you still
starves many years later i was so shook
that day i i wandered the city aimlessly
not knowing what to do was unemployed
for months after that we were in a
recession
to you my first boss now you feel what i
felt aimless suffocated
uh broke
broke as hell
right student loans stop him someone
stop them no keep going
you shouldn't have fired me when you did
[ __ ]
so your office smelled weird do it
do it do it all right
that was some good mentoring fun
was it the smoothest segment we've ever
had by no means
but that's how this [ __ ] goes in this
game
listen to me [ __ ] oh mandatory
fun's about two things
taking souls and digging holes as the
undertaker would say
so if you want to come up [ __ ] around
here for mandatory fun fiddle in your
two and three dollar super chats [ __ ]
appreciate it now you listen to me you
pieces of [ __ ]
i wipe my ass with people like you oh no
oh where's my [ __ ] oh my god
but those are the games when you're
dealing with a bunch of [ __ ]
[Applause]
that is your nephew still watching
that was my birthday gift to james he's
13. now he can hear it oh that's weird
he's basically an adult we got a poll
going in the chat it seems like jessica
had the best burn yeah guess what
they're saying
sally regent even tasha a second super
chat saying more money because i feel
this on a spiritual level yes
yes
as a one woman to uh in a field of oh no
offense guys of men in a nerd space
take it over
own that crap yeah once you get in
grab it by the damn neck and choke that
mother
you
you're the best you got it everybody's
got it as long as you know it yeah well
jessica you were a runaway winner of
that segment and i rewarded you the keys
that zach was losing
in his
old job you're fired
and i reward you the gift of taking over
a mandatory fund for the next two days
because i'll be gone baby
wedding in san diego
huddleston dab dab
dab
and with that being said
and with that segway we're gonna get
down into a nice discussion about
stranger things four um i don't know
which camera to look at oh look at this
one so we're getting into stranger
things four it's gonna have a little bit
of spoilery things but not too spoiled
but i just want to make it known that if
you have not watched a single episode
and you do want to watch stranger things
maybe go go to markiplier
go to another music
remember as we always say
cuties mute
losers go to other videos but they're
cuties they music
and go to another video no that's true
sorry my bad so tomorrow wendy has a
breakdown for stranger things season
four but today we'll be doing a
spoiler-free discussion for stranger
things four and for those of us here a
lot of us are in different parts of it
i've completely finished it i'm watching
the last episode again because it's
really great i want to know do we think
that vecna is the big bad is vec not
going to be the ultimate number one
uh just like the worst person to show up
in that franchise as in like controlling
all of the other main villains
well so the mind player the mind player
shows up in season two and the mind
flare is kind of intro is the like the
number one right my player is like the
one and then the demogorgon is season
one and it's just that little baby and
then we've got the spider monster in
season three but then we have the vacant
and now and it seems like the vector is
the most powerful out of all of them
except for i don't know how to comp
compare it to the mind flare right well
he talks right so that's like the
biggest difference yeah it's like it
communicates in english so we can like
we can identify
the other ones feel almost like
uh kaijus or or monsters that don't
speak you know they just we only see
their actions and their intentions speak
i don't think any of them ever really
talked about well i thought they i
thought they do it through they speak
through other yeah like when billy gets
possessed in season three right like
okay yeah
no
okay yes i i agree but this is an actual
the physical embodiment of this villain
speaks to the to its victims and their
dreams i thought am i spoiling you i
think becca is barb they left barbara in
the opposite way
yeah yeah and somebody took control of
the upside down and became veg now
that'd be sick as well that would be
pretty great now i don't know that
that's possible with some of the
timeline ramifications from the 50s and
whatever right but uh
but yeah i like that idea it seems like
they haven't like officially stated that
though we are getting we're getting two
more episodes of season four that are
dropping in july yeah a little over only
two more yeah but they're both they're
very long they're both like feature
length
yeah that makes more sense and then
we're getting an entire season five at
some point in the future all these child
actors will be in their mid-40s uh but
we are gonna get and presumably that is
the final season that is the summation
of the hawkins story yes if there are
more stranger things in the future it'll
have a different name or it'll be a
different cast or something like that do
you think the vector will be it seems
like every season has their different
villain yeah or has their different
antagonists so would it be do you think
it would be vecna going into the fifth
season i think it shouldn't be i think i
think that what makes
the show good is that there's a
different analogous d villain and i you
know maybe it'll be strad or somebody
like that you know straud von stoyevich
it's drawn from i don't know i kind of
like would like a villain to win yeah
and then like carries over because they
always win in the end all right levin
gets her powers back she does a little
this and then they win in the end i
don't i think a long-term villain that
kind of out that beats them and then
they have to get back together and like
okay take them down but i i could see a
newbie i don't mind having 11 beat all
the time it's more so that i'm like i'm
getting really irritated with these
justifications these kids are having
knowing exactly what's happening and no
adult does yeah that is true like all
the 15 year olds are like no it's this
exact type of monster that can be killed
only this way and the adults are like
we think it might be an electronical
anomaly
speakers that's that's the trope of like
uh adults don't listen to kids right
thing that's et that's goonies that's
everything right and and you're right it
does get stretched to credulity when
it's over the course of
multiple lines at least hopper should
know now you know uh that anything that
goes wrong in hawkins i mean robber
maybe no immediately rest in paradise i
assume having no spoilers but like
should if there anything went wrong
uh should have should be like oh that's
the upside down well even this season it
doesn't support unless you say that like
the adults the other residents of
hawkins keep referring to they call it
the mall fire the end of season three
right like so they're not like oh there
was a giant like human sludge made
monster that was terrorizing our city
they they know there's been a ton of
tragedy and death and things like that
they don't they're unaware of all the
supernatural element of it they know
that they're kind of at this point a
cursed city they don't know it's a
literal curse that leads to another
world right but um that is
that makes me that just makes me
irritated but speaking of the other
world
there is a lot in this season that it's
like what and i was yelling at daschle
about this what are the limits to the
upside down because what we got in
season two was when will was in his
trance they played like can i should i
stay or should i go and he was able to
talk in morse code and then in this
season we're getting like the kate bush
story or the kate bush song and it's
like okay it seems like and you can
still hear people from the outside of
the um upside down they can still hear
and you have the light so i'm like what
is the limit
where does it end where does it end it
seems like we can talk through it and we
can do all these other things with it
are we able to like just keep going back
and forth through it
yeah and like sometimes you physically
can go to it like when you go through a
portal right but other times it seems
like you kind of just get mentally
sucked there
right yeah so it's dearth wealth all
over again earth wealth is just stuck
it's not mentally stuck i mean i guess
it's an idea of like if it is a
dimension it's like a separate dimension
and it's intersecting with our dimension
in a weird way there's ways to just like
slip in and out of it and maybe it
doesn't operate like a third dimensional
plane it has like a fourth dimension
where it's manipulating time in space in
a weird way that we don't understand i
mean it's science fiction
that's true it doesn't have his stronger
rules and every antagonist has their
like own little like personal little
little thing to it so they can like it's
like i can like mentally manipulate you
while one's like i can only contact you
if i physically i mean i really hope
this won't be the answer but i really
wish that back in season one they filmed
a scene where it's just like that's the
end of the game and this whole show is
just like
you i think
it's
all bs it's all in their mind and that's
why things don't make sense because like
they're they're making the story up as
they go and they're just playing this
game and the very end of the whole
series is like none of this actually
happened it was all just i like it i
love the idea that this is all coming
from the imagination of kids and they
still give themselves a ton of problems
and issues growing up right like you
know relationship problems and fights
with their parents and stuff like that
you mentioned you're maybe a little
sick and and there's a reason they have
the enemy defeated the big bad gets
defeated at the end of everything
right yeah it's good storytelling we
kind of get to end on like a positive
note but
one thing this show is not done
is kill any of the main cast yeah we
usually get we get new characters
introduced we got billy we got sean
astin's character they get introduced
they usually get killed off from the
same season and then sometimes they get
introduced like the maya hawk character
or whatever and the max character and
then they stick around for a couple
seasons
will we lose a main cast character
somebody's got i want i want it to be
nancy and i think nancy's a good one to
die because nancy is close to the
parents close to the teenagers close to
the kids so it's like that person dying
and that's also a sister a sibling
because they didn't care about billy
dying they were like that guy sucked
anyway
max is the only person that's like that
was my brother everyone's like we don't
care he was also slightly racist
he didn't want me dating you for a
reason but it was uh nancy if she dies
that will be like a game changer yeah
she's kind of the kind of
the heart she's a good person she's kind
of at the heart of the show too yeah i
want her to die it would also like yeah
with jonathan you wanted her
i want her to die with jonathan being in
california and her here and doing all
these things i'm like
yeah it'll ripple everything throw in
the chat now we're talking maybe you've
already seen this chunk of episodes
we're talking at the end of of the
entirety of season four in july
who do you think might die because i
mean there's also a lot of these young
actors maybe they're ready to move on in
their careers
for another season maybe dustin
yeah maybe dustin goes in a wood chipper
they just toss them in there on an
unrelated story
maybe just trips and falls into a into a
wood chipper dustin will be the uh my
family was like what if it's dustin and
i was like i think dustin will be the
last one to go yeah do like stranger
things season 50. yeah he's done another
prank show he's going to be like
what's his name from snl he's not keenan
but he's going to be the oh
yeah keenan's been there million years
well well i mean because he kind of
looks like him too anyways daryl hammond
no yes daryl him
god love it oh my gosh the big guy
[Laughter]
um that's the ticket well now i'll even
throw out do you think there's a chance
the final season i know we're already
speculating about the final season we
haven't even finished this one
that one of the core cast members is the
villain
they get possessed or i don't know they
go to the dark side a little bit or
something like that
barb comes
i think mike verse 11 would be the you
know the ultimate like
because you know it's like 11's always
she has her anger issues that make her
slightly
unpredictable even though she tries to
help friends help friends help each
other but what if mike presented such a
danger oh you know and the betrayal of
mike you know becoming possessed or bad
caused her to accidentally kill him
huh i think if anyone i i agree with
tommy but in the way that i think it
would be better if eleven like
uh like ironmans it and has to die in
order to like yeah it doesn't seem like
they kind of did that at season one
right wasn't that kind of like
11 kind of died at the end but i know
but they did the like assumed death and
then just pulling those eggos out of the
the hidey hole
give me another character that
literally was on a show for maybe two
episodes and got the most merchandise
because barb was the like yes barb had
towels barb had like
uh
bricks
uh bruno saying is nancy going back to
steve
no she i okay
this is my beef with nancy and dating
whoa
we all were like oh nancy go with
jonathan go with steve and now i'm like
nancy stop ruining people's lives
because as soon as you step in and start
loving people they start dying almost so
it's like
well no what i think is her fault is
like nancy be with yourself find
yourself she went off on steve in like
the second or no the first season when
barb passed away and it was like you we
could have saved barb and i'm like yeah
you could have if you weren't with steve
and then with jonathan now she's like
always beefing and i'm like yeah you
just should be with yourself you should
figure out yourself spend some time and
that's what we call
secret mandatory fun hit the graphics
across the coals again
you thought you were safe dancing no
no not here oh no
it could happen any time it was a back
that's right a little backdoor fun
mandatory style eddie with uh
with steve anyways eddie munson oh okay
yeah oh eddie munson big i mean does
eddie munson survive this season yes he
does he's going to be 53 next year
he's older than me
aaron scott throwing in the chat how
crazy would it be if this was uh the
whole series was will byers in a in like
a six-year coma he crashed his bike into
a tree in season one and this has all
been in his like coma dream that's fine
but the d and d game is bad yeah yeah i
agree i agree sally regent team uh uh
said i think we're gonna get season two
folks oh i think that was i think that
was obvious
well we'll get a dark spin-off you
caprita though saying i think season
four is as good as season one oh hashtag
where
where the is mt cameo
is where is the where is the empty
camera
you know we just gotta we gotta find him
first that's right he's at large so if
somebody uh stumbles in the wilderness
across the blue dungeon uh with a young
man in there uh spinning yarns about
doctor strange uh let us know but do you
guys think season four is the best
season yet as good as season one scary
season yeah
a lot of people are saying this season
four is the best season and i just
definitely lead more horror than sci-fi
i think yeah it's more uh
nightmare on elm street season four the
best season yet
i've heard
stranger things
daschle take the camera off the tripod
and throw it at his head
stranger things basically what would
happen if a sitcom took place in the
x-files universe oh
yes the side is in the same small town
right now has got to go all over the
country does make me think of like buffy
the vampire slayer where it's like this
town is a problem someone needs to do
something about it like blow this town
up they should all blow it up they
should all move well and it's like joyce
took her family to california they
should have stayed in california in fact
everybody should have moved to to
different places they're like we gotta
stay here this is
i want to point out someone made a death
prediction uh for jonathan which it is
an 80s homage and he is taken to drugs
this season no spoilers yeah and there
is a you know pretty classic rule in
horror movies in the 80s that if you
dabble with the drugs you dabble with it
morgan if you if you wander off from
your cabin to go smoke some reefer in
the woods
the the slasher is going to get you same
thing with sex that's right but he's not
the virgin none of them are the virgin
or the teens the teens teens
might be virgins
killing the druggie in a movie
i've heard strangers okay
you can't keep getting away with it
oh my gosh
okay okay
where is it chloe was asking i want to
know how the first victims of the vacna
are in the upside down when we see this
one there's a spoiler and then this is
the spoiler question is it not
this is the early yeah this is episode
three or four i believe it's not episode
three because i've seen episode three
and i didn't know that that was well
well you also thought someone wasn't in
the show who was in this that also
doing drugs before the break room well
i've heard
not true
i'd never do drugs
thank you tommy uh i like that the
spoiler bar is still is it still on the
spoiler oh
my god tommy just did a line on
[Music]
is my mic pack broken yeah
okay well now now that we've uh
destroyed parties
thank you you know what we'll probably
check in maybe early next week when
everybody's finished stranger things
maybe we'll also get some some promo for
this uh second half of the season
that'll be coming in july pretty soon
we'll be excited for that and we'll
definitely be covering that and check
out whitney van laningham's breakdown of
the entirety of the season coming out on
the channel tomorrow she's been putting
in a lot of work on that it should be
really really good we're all excited to
watch that um
oh and then we're getting our obi-wan
episode three breakdown eric is gonna
have that out on the channel tomorrow as
well so we got a lot of really really
nice content coming out in the next
couple days uh tommy's gonna be gone the
rest of the week we wish you well and
thank you pray for me guys pray for me
yeah i will not i'm just going to a
wedding but you know it never hurts to
be
people
but we'll have some really fun uh guest
panelists with us we thank you all thank
you to everybody that was uh live with
us in the chat or if you're watching
this in three days you know what we
value you yeah just as much maybe you're
getting hooked on this show catching it
up later and then you can start joining
us live at 3 p.m pacific every weekday
um someone paid 10 dollars for jess to
do the r2d2 scream and i don't know if
jess is at your price point yeah is that
a good i just want to make sure that
they got it yeah give them 10 worth of
it
wow
yes easily easily easy uh thank you all
so much for joining us in the break room
we'll see you tomorrow
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
because you're on your